bonjour douglas gates merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france qu'est
ce qu'il faut attendre de ce rendez vous
entre mike pompéo m&a fredriksen est-ce
que washington et copenhague peuvent se
rabibocher oui c'est la normalisation de
relations diplomatiques à la plaine des
détails stratégique entre les états unis
danemark d'abord l'émission d' autant en
irak le danemark va prendre le contrôle
de cette mission la fin de l'année donc
ils vont discuter les détails de sa et
mike trempé a dit le coran est presque
qu'ils ont des disputes et ça mais en
plus hier les autres choses même en
l'offensive des états unis contre la
chine
la plupart de pays en europe ne sont pas
encore dans une corde avec les états
unis le danemark et la grande-bretagne y
est finalement il y a les questions de
gazoducs russes qui eux ne peut être on
va discuter le groenland est un
territoire on le sait très convoité donc
par les etats-unis et par la chine
et quel est l'enjeu véritablement est ce
que le groenland est à vendre
arnaud infecte un jeu maristes a demandé
à maman ps il est le premier ministre si
l'on discuté sai noi n'ont pas abordé ce
sujet c'était en espèrant plaisanterie
aussi nord c'était ridicule d'acheter le
greenland souvent tu
ministration 30 ne semble pas comprendre
les sentiments de souveraineté des
autres pays mais en disant ça les états
unis on aurait ouvert un consulat tu en
ue qu ils ont toujours une base aérienne
à tulle est donc les états unis hôte est
entrée stratégique et c'est ça que leur
bêtise de dole on trempe a indiqué que
les états unis entre ne gagne de
l'entrée stratégique dans la région
arctique à cause de l'effondrement de la
glace les veaux martin ou 20 et le grand
manque comme vous avez bien dit vendre
un portage et tout pour montrer à cette
nouvelle année dit errani est ce que les
états unis veulent se poser en médiateur
entre le danemark et le bois non non non
pas du tout
plus tôt m les entrailles de mike campé
au seco le groupe que le dément que
contribuer au cloud proche malade ou
pour cent de son de son produit national
dans l'otan que il continue encore et
dans la baltique
mais les questions de green que de
grands landes n'était pas sur le menu
c'était vraiment un accident ou une
sorte de tweets de présidente
mais l'heure reste l'établissement de
déploiement des tacles lancerait pas
dans cet enjeu
ils ont déjà de problèmes avec l'europe
parce que maintenant les etats-unis
cherchent les allié dans leur guerre
commerciale dans leurs sanctions contre
la chine et la plupart des pays
européens ne sont pas intéressés
l'allemande le plus important est marié
en europe réfute catégoriquement de
faire
rien que le diplomatie la france a
reconnu la souveraineté de la chine et
est donc avec le demande
le sens que c'est un pays qui est
visitable par l'administration trempe
d'ailleurs c'est une région est complète
et beaucoup des sites à teneur attendre
que le règne de 30 soit fini et quels
sont les autres enjeux de cette
rencontre entre les américains et les
danois aujourd'hui we really à notre
politique qui consomment en six lots
liautaud que le gazoduc nordstream ou
deux qui l'aidait qui passe entre la
russie et la main qui passe traverse les
eaux danoises
il leur manque a donné son accord à
cette gazeau tous les états unis ont
imposé des sanctions sur les entreprises
qui travaillent sur cette base aux docks
les etats-unis ont peur que en compte
disons plus des gaz de plus de doute que
les européennes soit en tigre est plutôt
dépendant plus tôt cela aussi est donc
ils n'ont pas parlé mais c'est tout à
fait plausible que le sujet était abordé
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions du
glay férié il s'agit rappelle que vous
êtes professeur de droit et spécialiste
de la politique américaine